y subrayaron los riesgos riesgos de
nuevos ataques con por ejemplo carros
bomba camiones bomba nuevas personas que
se inmolen y también mencionar el riesgo
de de misiles que pueden ser en vez
proyectados hacia aviones y hacia el
aeropuerto al respecto pues en los
generales dijeron que se va a tratar de
empujar el perímetro de alejar a la
gente del aire del aeropuerto de las
fronteras del aeropuerto del espacio
aéreo se hablará con los talibanes es
algo que mencionaron varias veces desde
el pentágono ya hay comunicación con los
talibanes se acercarán aún más con los
talibanes a pesar de que no hay del todo
confianza para evitar futuros ataques y
obviamente pues se seguirá con la
campaña de vuelos de drones y de otro
tipo de aviones para poder pues
asegurarse que no hayan nuevamente más
atentados sobre todo en
y dijo el de la portavoz del pentágono
n a posibles atentados contra aviones
personas que lleven bombas que logren
entrar bombas a los aviones y que pueda
ser un riesgo aún más grande ahora está
podría acelerar el proceso de evacuación
cristóbal hubo complicidad de los
talibanes en los ataques que han dicho
desde el pentágono al respecto
lo que muchos periodistas le preguntaron
a los generales del pentágono es porque
estos terroristas lograron pasar los los
checkpoints los puntos de revisión
varios puntos de retén que hay que pasar
antes de llegar a las puertas de el
aeropuerto y lo que respondió el general
uno de los generales hay en el pentágono
fue lo que no cree que la complicidad
por parte de los talibanes en estos
ataques que ellos seguirán en
conversación y compartiendo información
de seguridad para que los talibanes
también ayuden en el proceso de pueden
capturar posibles terroristas y gente
que quiere hacer más atentados le doy un
dato hoy a las 5 de la tarde hora de
washington hablar al presidente yo bailé
desde la casa ahora